Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome to hand simulator now
I think the title of the game explains everything that we're about to get into there's um...
Wait, this is a game. Ah fuck, i was gonna click. I don't know how to play this so if I'm gonna be dueling someone whoa
I don't know how to due- oh
Oh my God, it's t its that t game. How do I lower o oh with the mouse wheel?
Huh, well I like to grip my guns sidesaddle like let's grab one of these bad boys
I hope there's someone on the other side of this range
That's struggling to get this bullet into his gun as much as I is cuz oh oh
ah
Ha ha ha so if I hit a and space, I daintily
daintily
daintily I daintily grab I don't even know how did someone have 5 kills ok wait
Let's think about this logically you would grab a gun with the other
hand
The oth- there we go. You would grab a gun with the other hand get out of here hand
I don't want to see you around these parts again
You would grab it kind of not quite exactly but kind of like this you would grab with some firm
fingers oh
Yeah, that's a, not a good good grip but I'm gonna. I'm gonna just give myself credit for when's credits. Do there we go
I twisted it, okay. I'm gonna slap the side just like hey, buddy
You're doing a great job there a good job with you, whoa
But did do it'll dial Deedle down grab okay lift lift. Hey, we've got liftoff
Hey prepare to die. I mean even though this obviously is not loaded at all
Let's assume that killed you let's just assume all right no
I don't know where you think you're going gun, but can you?
you
hey, I
Come on a second here. Why don't you?
Just get back on the goddamn table before I get shot in the fucking face
How about that lift it up lift it up
So I got to turn it a little bit over to my other hand ah so it stays there, okay?
Then I'm gonna point my poker. That's what I call this finger here
Open up the chamber Barrel I get all pen you stupid revolver piece of shit. Oh
Man, I think you only win this duel by just having more patience than the other guy who oh I can't
Oh, not quite lower it lower
It lower and drag that's what Markie likes. I wish I didn't say that already
I'm gonna regret that in gif form later, but
Okay, how about I just slam my fingy into the hammer until oh get fingied? Oh?
Yeah, well that did not work either
Excuse you ah whoa
Okay, I've cocked it. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy
Is there anybody even over there in oh?
Bang, oh didn't have a bull,(faintly) oh fuck
Yeah, I know I
Hear you bird complaining about how bad I am I don't need that bullshit
how about you take some of who's not that that's not what I wanted you to take take some of my pinkie button what then
Where's my pinkie button alright you take some of this because that's the best I can give you a good old quarian hello
I gotta figure out how to put a bullet in you which might mean I'm gonna be here awhile, but woo dainty got it I
Seem to be pushing down all the buttons, but apparently it doesn't like that too much, but I've got a nice
sock
Solid Grip okay, wait hang on. I've got a nice. I've got a nice
solid
Grip on this it's a deadly if you know what I?
Mean maybe I should have done the tutorial
Maybe that'd be a good idea. You know what I'm gonna do that. I'm gonna get the old hand simulator tutorial
There's no tutorial here. What is this hey flip this fling? Oh? Oh, this is oddly sexual
Let's lift it up blitz. Oh, it's a cranky yank it. I'm cranked. I crunked it. Oh
oh camera rotating, Oh
There is a person down there, or there was were
I guess I can't like you there was no point in that before so hang on
Let me see if I can get this snub nose bullshit. I got I like scootch the dootch there
We go get it to the right hand shape
I can't actually bend my wrist
So I gotta just flop all I got everyone do the flop indeed look at that like a bowss
Like a boos bowss lift it raise it get it good switch alright
So let's see if there's actually a dude donger here, can you dude on this dude donger you are you kitten me?
Are you shitting my dork got it? That's gotta be it oh
Dip go you sack of shit?
I'm just grunting and thrusted well this went awry ah
Open you bastard. Let me just slap that on the table. There you slide
Okay, got it nailed it okay, so let's switch around give it the old switcheroo. I'm gonna look down at you because you're
Inferior to me you machine, and I'm gonna figure out how to poke a good poking angle oh
ah
I got it
Okay, so that's good. That's right. That's nice. That's tizight
I grab one of these a bada boies. Nope if I grab one of these a bada Boies bad boys
I got a bad boy. Okay. I'm assuming. This is not Gonna. Go easy in this one nope
You're gonna be a little too particular aintcha Argh i just wanna shoot you once, did i getcha?
No, you're right there. You're angled up so good
Oh, that's such a good angle on that this would be argh and it was perfect
I got it. I got it. I got it. This is the one this is the one okay whoo alright ah
ah oh
No
Don't dangle out don't dangle out don't dangle out don't dangle out whoa
ahh your right theere, ohh dididi, wahaha! Hahaha
Let me give that old belly slap to Pop that bad boy in there clunk. I said clunk
Aha
Right it's in there now. I got to pull the hammer back like 15 bajillion times
But I think I'm ready for that one okay, so I think I gotta go switchy handy, okay?
So long as I don't drop this son of a bitch or anything like that. That would be I'll be hilariously a little wooden
oh
That means that no amy waime too. Good right there
Okay, switch hands. Yeah. We're getting it. We're learning
Hands is how hard it was as a baby to shoot a gun this is why you guys your experience as a baby like
Did you have trouble loading your revolver right? Let's slam the hammer down
Oh, no angle this give the old devil horns there because we're gonna need it. I need a little bit Satanic intervention here
Oh yeah, yeah, oh you had that yeah? Oh, okay?
It's a downward and a clicky motion okay, so I know this isn't the right one
But I'm gonna try to fire it anyway
Just because I need duke in the hole or are you not in the hole getting that in that Trigger hole?
Click oh it shot
Did I hit it I'm going to assume. I hit it I got no points that means I hit it. Yes
That means I missed zero that's what that means try the old ye old spinners here, so the oh boy. Oh
boy
Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy
Ed boy, that's not what I wanted I got a pen I
Got a pen put in my name here oppa do ba ba Ba edit boob Em
oh
my God Em
a our
k-and that
Spells mark. I got it. Okay, but let's get to what you all were really here for which is this sweet
sweet
There's no way. I'm ever going to get this to Spin am I oh my finger is through that hey
Oh, I thought I had yet. As I scooped it, okay
I'm a I got dangling her ah you bastard you clumsy piece of poo ah not quite
Not quite pick yeah, oh, no
oh
I had it. I was that cast a spell go
It's a feisty one. Oh, it's fidgeting. Oh wait
No, do I do I have it if I let go of my ring finger?
No, not that finger. I even thought of it in my head. I had it oh
I just gonna give myself the old this treatment cuz I deserve it
Nope, what the pink one, you okay? I got it
That's not good let go of middle, okay?
It's in the palm of my hand take it from my palm young
Grasshopper this doesn't actually help me any more than it picking up from the table, but I'm just gonna do it anyway - hey
Ho hey ho hey ho I got it no, don't got  it son of a spinning. It was spinning. I saw it
Right out of my hand. How can you even grab that thing squeeze harder than you've ever squoze?
Is that your hardest squooze no that's not your hardest squoze squoze harder, please
Squoze with your heart's content entire. Oh, that's not squozen. Oh
oh
My God oh my God. Oh my God. Oh, oh
Okay, just leave it right there
That's perfect
Switch okay now. I'm gonna give this the old Flicka Roo, just gonna point point oh
I don't like that. Okay. We're gonna boink oh, it's
Burnin it's bad
Yes, oh, just graze. It like a wheel
Whoa! I got an achievement!  yeah that was adequate Spin okay, so anyway that is hand simulator
Thank you everybody so much for watching I feel like I wasted my time completely
But maybe you guys didn't so I hope you enjoyed it
so
Thank you everybody so much for watching let me know what you thought it's down the comments below and if you want to duel me
Let me know that as well. Thanks again, and as always I will see you in the next video